♪♪
Narrator: TO MAKE EACH
INLAID CABINET DOOR,
A WOODWORKER GLUES THE PATTERN
ONTO THE WOOD,
MAKING SURE THAT IT'S
PERFECTLY CENTERED.
THEN, USING A ROUTER, HE CUTS
ABOUT 3 MILLIMETERS DEEP,
MAKING A GROOVE
ALONG THE PATTERN'S PERIMETER
AND CUTTING OUT THE PARTS
THAT WILL BE INLAID
WITH MOTHER-OF-PEARL.
♪♪
MEANWHILE, USING ANOTHER COPY
OF THE PATTERN,
A WORKER MAKES TEMPLATES
BY CUTTING OUT THE SAME PARTS
THE WOODWORKER ROUTED
OUT OF THE CABINET DOOR.
EACH TEMPLATE IS MARKED
EITHER PINK, WHITE, OR GREEN.
SHE GLUES IT INTO
A 3-MILLIMETER-THICK PIECE
OF THE CORRESPONDING COLOR
OF MOTHER-OF-PEARL.
THE NEXT CRAFTSPERSON
TAKES ONE PIECE AT A TIME
AND, HOLDING IT STEADY
WITH PLIERS,
CAREFULLY SAWS
AROUND THE TEMPLATE
WITH A 1-MILLIMETER-WIDE BLADE.
ONCE SHE HAS CUT
ALL THE PIECES,
SHE REASSEMBLES THE PATTERN.
THE NEXT CRAFTSPERSON
SPREADS ADHESIVE PASTE
INTO THE CUTOUTS
IN THE CABINET DOOR.
THEN HE FILLS EACH CUTOUT
WITH ITS CORRESPONDING PIECE
OF MOTHER-OF-PEARL.
FIVE HOURS FROM NOW,
ONCE THE ADHESIVE HAS DRIED,
HE RUNS A SANDER OVER THE DESIGN
TO REMOVE THE PAPER
AND EXCESS ADHESIVE,
SMOOTH THE WOOD,
AND POLISH THE MOTHER-OF-PEARL.
THEN AN ARTIST ETCHES FINE
DETAIL INTO THE MOTHER-OF-PEARL.
THIS PROVIDES TEXTURE,
DIMENSION, AND EXPRESSION
TO OBJECTS AND CHARACTERS
WHICH, UNTIL NOW,
WERE MERELY BLANK SHAPES.